scenes of Destruction along Mexico's
Southwestern Coast this is the aftermath
of hurricane Otis after making landfall
near the resort city of Acapulco home to
some 1 million
people our house is a total loss my
mattresses my documents my children's my
grandchildren's things it's a total
loss scientists say Otis strengthened
quickly just before it hit akapulko many
were caught off guard were some models
that were predicting a slight
intensification before landfall but
nothing obviously to the extent that was
seen and um you know I I think we can't
really blame the models since this was a
you know broke all records in terms of
Rapid
intensification but you know both the
the models and the National Hurricane
Center we certainly not expecting this
kind of
development power and communication
lines are down and many streets and
bridges are covered in mud thousands of
members of the Armed Forces have been
deployed to help with the cleanup
operations forecasters have described
Otis as a catastrophic hurricane it's
also believed to be the first Eastern
Pacific hurricane ever recorded to make
landfall in Mexico as a category 5
Manuel rapalo Al
jazer make sure to subscribe to our
channel to get the latest news from Al
jazer